[Music]
expect all kinds of stunts and magic in
the upcoming Marvel movie Black Panther
hits theaters February 16th
look at this presale tickets for opening
night
sold out in 15 minutes and I caught up
with the all-star cast starting with the
bad guy Michael B Jordan is my
responsibility to make sure that Wakanda
does not fall into the hands of a person
like you how Rick did you have to get
for this movie I work pretty hard for
this one trying to be the villain in
this one was that your hair it was your
hair in the 130 I grew it out for about
a year and a half and then I then I got
saw a little bit a little bit of extra
help meet the stars of Marvel's next
hottest movie chadwick boseman is black
panther Michael B Jordan the villain the
Walking Dead's Danai gurira is a female
warrior Lupita Nyong'o is also but check
it out this film is so highly
anticipated hashtag black panther sol it
even Lupita couldn't get tickets to the
already sold out opening night they
wouldn't know I was unable to buy
tickets that's insane
I wasn't working with Michael and
Chadwick they bring their sexy to this
booth oh we all do how did you get into
black panther shape fight training
lifting weights running we needed to get
our bodies ready for it so our workouts
were extremely already the stars are
being welcomed into the Marvel superhero
universe sterling K Brown is also in the
film he plays a person from Black
Panthers past people ready for this like
you're gonna get all the bells and
whistles that you get from a Marvel film
this movie works on all of us it's
beautiful cannot wait in some of the
Black Panther casts are presenting
tonight at the n-double-a-cp Image
Awards which air live on TV 1 make sure
you check it out so many stars will be
on hand to celebrate excellence in so
many different disciplines and it's
perfect that it occurs on the same day
that we celebrate dr. Martin Luther King
jr.
[Music]
you